well thank you guys all for coming
um it sounded like it was way more
exciting out on the floor uh
so uh this is let's get scary and
continuously deploy database changes
um
yeah my name is Dan Malott I am the head
of platform and infrastructure for uh
economic uh economic is accounting
software uh for small and medium-sized
businesses in Denmark
uh we have approximately 182 000
customers and the teams that I manage
are responsible for the foundation of
the software so we we build the
foundation we take care of the
infrastructure that our amazing product
devs uh build features on
um
we are a company that is a member of the
visma group as well
um if you're interested in a job visma
is hiring now I've said the bit that
they give me time to come to the
conference for
um so I still consider myself a software
developer
um
even though I've been mainly developing
PowerPoints recently
uh
I've also been a DBA on occasion I had a
lot more hair then
and uh most of my experiences with
Microsoft Technology
done a bit of work with some other
database products uh
some other programming languages notably
the four letter one
um and I referee and play Ice Hockey
um so
when my wife and I decided to relocate
from the United States coming somewhere
ice hockey has played was really
important
so we chose Denmark because we wanted
bad ice hockey
what are we going to talk about here
um
so I can't see you very well but how
many people out there are developers
primarily in your in your day-to-day job
looks like almost everybody
um
so the the CI CD thing is is going to be
just uh covering the bases Refresher
um
we'll talk about why data is a problem
in particular when we when we think
about continuous integration continuous
deployment data can be a huge problem
um
we'll talk about how you modify the data
model safely
and maybe not so safely
um I'll do a bit of touching on
automated testing
we'll close out with some demos about
how you do this state-based versus
migration based and I've chosen a couple
of off-the-shelf tools for that
at my company we've actually built our
own tooling to do uh to do a
migration-based deployment and I'll talk
about why that was chosen as well
yeah so
so you want to automate some stuff right
we're developers we're lazy so
automation's great
continuous integration we're all
familiar with this right you merge your
code in or you push your code up make a
pull request and an automated build
happens you get immediate feedback about
whether or not your changes will compile
not work compile
and then continuous deployment is we
take that artifact that we just created
with the continuous integration build
and we deploy it
um
so every change can be pushed
automatically assuming all your tests
have passed right
how many people have a test environment
how many people have a dedicated
production environment
that's pretty good
my teams manage 15 acceptance
environments to allow our developers to
test a lot of features in parallel
so
it's cool right so cicd right and we're
really used to doing this with our
application code right whether you're
writing it in c-sharp in Java in Python
and
Ruby
God help you
um
but databases are a lot harder right
and and there's a reason for that
the data is a problem
right data is not application code
data is
records the state of your application
right so when you change the state of
your application you have to be careful
that you don't lose something important
right
if we think about it from a programming
perspective our data is stored as a
resource
right yeah anybody work with the old.net
resx files
yeah
I back when I had hair
um
right that that's data
right so whether we're starting in a
resx file in Json in a relational
database in table storage in the cloud
whatever right data is a resource right
and it should be permanent
um although not too permanent because
we all have regulatory regimes one in
particular that say we need to be able
to delete data
if somebody asks us to
it's a good thing all those systems that
we built were designed after that
regulation came into effect
um
and so when we think about changing the
data model right so data model is code
right when we build a data model we do
it declaratively this is what our data
should look like tables or objects or
whatever you have right but if you
change the data model you might lose
data
um and losing data without meaning to is
bad right
um
and to compound this our code and our
data model are intertwined
right no no one has built the orm that
does things magically
although people are trying
right
so your code has to know what the data
model looks like
right in some cases your data model has
to know what the code looks like
in particular if you think about
indexing right
an index is an opinion about the code
yeah so losing data is bad which means
that we need to have a strategy when we
go to change the data model so that we
don't lose data or know that we're
losing data
and we all have backups right
right
I've got some laughter up there that's
not good
um
and everybody's tested them
yeah
you know this is a place where the cloud
has really changed things as an aside
like you know if you're running Azure
SQL database
which is what I which is what I have for
the demos it's great I've I've got a
backup there I didn't have to do
anything
now I always keep seven days of backups
because I'm cheap but it's there and if
I had an Enterprise budget I could keep
a little bit more
yeah so how many people out there have a
data store that is the authoritative
source for that data
this is the day this is the store
for the data in the organization and
it's the one that is authoritative all
the other any place else that's copied
is just a copy like this is the original
yeah I got a couple
how many of you don't know
I got a couple okay thank you for your
honesty
um yeah so this is interesting right
most of my work has been on
transactional databases and
transactional databases that are
the
source of Truth for the data so that
when it gets copied into a reporting
environment or into a CSV format those
things are just snapshots of a point in
time based on what's in the
transactional database not everybody has
that right
some sometimes we're we're dealing with
an external data source sometimes we're
you know
grabbing a copy from somewhere else in
our organization and just working with
it that's okay
so but if you do right if this is the
authoritative data
um then you might want to think about
taking some more care when we change the
data model which I'll start talking
about here in a second how we do that
um
mainly because
if
so one of the databases that one of my
teams manages is our user store
right and it's
this is you know the users uh what SKU
they've bought
what their permissions are their email
address things of that nature right
and we feed this data other places
so
RBI folks use this data
to generate use of statistics and our
sales people use this data from bi to to
do upselling right like hey
you're using this feature a bunch maybe
you should use this one or buy this one
right
so when we make changes to our data
model
we need to tell people
and that means you have to talk to
people across your organization
um
and uh
talking talking to people is scary
uh-huh
and they're all I'd also need to be more
gates
right so
everyone has an automated test Suite
that perfectly covers all of the use
cases of their application
fair right yeah no none of us do
their gaps right
but it means that when you're making a
change that changes your data structure
or potentially changes the data
you really need to make sure that you're
either covered with the automated tests
you do have because we've all got some
or you have a test plan
um
because fun story so uh and I'll come
back to this a couple of times
one of the projects that we're doing
right now is we have some tables that
are actually running out of integers
on their identity columns
um so the the Danish government and
their Infinite Wisdom
passed a law last year that says every
every business that has a CVR right a
vat number
has to use an electronic accounting
software
and
part of the electronic accounting
software that we have that we offer is
we manage a lot of files right invoices
you know proceeds
other other files right
well
it turns out that
2 billion was plenty when the system was
designed in 1997.
but it's not in 2023
so
we're actually running out of integers
um
and
it has taken us a while to make this
change because
changing from in to Big end right not a
big deal but it's taking us a while to
make this change because testing this is
really complex and our documentation is
not the best
um
not a not a negative just uh yeah
it's 25 year old software
right
so how do we change the data model
safely
and how do we maybe not change it safely
too
okay
so generally if you're adding things to
your database to your data model
this is fine
right
um
now there are some cases where like if
you're adding a table or an index or
um
something like that like make sure
there's enough space
um
so the example I was just talking about
were actually instead of just upsizing
the column on the table because that
would take
well we tried it and it took 18 hours
and then we killed it
um
so we're actually copying the data into
another table well that's
that space
and uh
our DBA was like um so we're running out
of space on the drive
oh yeah
right so check with the DBA team if
there's storage
um
add the table to whatever MDM you have
right that's that's sort of a good
you know
good rule of thumb anyway
right same with a view add to MDM check
your indexing if you're adding a view
check indexing because
make sure there's an index that supports
the query the view is executing
um other things yeah it's generally fine
right
um
now if you're adding a trigger tell the
dbas and buy them beer or drink of their
choice
maybe don't buy it in Norway uh
come down to Denmark and buy your beer
come back
um
and then you know if you're if you're
adding a column right no one ever ever
does select star in production code
so that's definitely safe
right but yeah this is fine
for the most part
um
but you do have a backup right because
we're going to talk about removing
things next
um
yeah
so if we drop things after a backup what
do we have to do
um
yeah
generally again this is pretty much fine
as long as we've made sure to preserve
the data
um now I'm I'm very clearly American
right
um
so we have a few more regulatory regimes
than just the gdpr
um but they're all pretty consistent on
this one like don't lose data unless you
absolutely mean to
right
so if you're dropping a table right
update MDM make sure you've got a copy
of the data somewhere
somewhere
if you're updating you know if you're
dropping a view right again we want to
update MDM maybe we want to drop some
indexes too
story procedures constraints fine
one thing on constraints is
business logic is important and we
generally enforce it via constraints
because it isn't being enforced at the
application Level or because we don't
trust the developers who are working on
that
to enforce it at the application Level
um
and I don't want to get into a
conversation about check at every level
because that
that's just off topic
um
but yeah
if you're dropping a constraint make
sure it's not needed
like are you sure are you sure we want
this column to be nullable
and maybe explain to the product owner
why that might be a bad thing
um
again
you know if you drive if you're dropping
a trigger now you're gonna get that beer
money back
in the form of beer
and uh yeah column just make sure you've
got the data
again these these are not not really
really awkward operations
what are the off guard operations where
when we talk about
uh
altering the data model
so I'm not going to work in the the joke
about naming things and
off by one errors and all that but
naming things is hard and renaming
things is even harder
right
um
it's it's the same as like if you go
into your code okay like maybe we have
writer or IntelliJ if you're in that
world or whatever and we have got really
great refactoring tools
right
but how many people have gone into code
and gone I need to rename this thing but
it's like in some strings in some places
and so I'm just gonna do like a find all
and replace
and then all of a sudden the code
doesn't compile
I got crap what did I do
yeah so
let's talk about renaming a column right
now
when you rename a column
you're going to break
every query that depends on that column
name
it will no longer run
it will give you an error and it will if
you're working with SQL Server B
reasonably comprehensible
for SQL Server right
but you know this is pretty easy right
we can
for if we're doing this sort of
generically we can add a column set it
set some names or set some data right
copy the data into a drop of the column
um
forward SQL Server world we have a nice
convenient stored procedure for this
um but like I said this is a huge
breaking change so
you might want to add an alias to the
table and Alias to that column on the
table a computed column right
and you might want to run it this way
for a while
just until you make sure that you've
gotten all the consuming code
this is a place where observability can
really help right
so we've made a
we've been making a bunch of changes
where we we change the way things are
called
and we set a monitor in datadog
to say hey this is still being called
this way and you can do it the same way
with your with your computed column name
right
set a monitor like hey this thing's
still being some some query somewhere is
still using this old column name so you
can track it down
renaming a table
um
syntax is really easy but again you're
going to break everything
that depends on that table including the
downstream
things to consume it right bi
other maybe you know that that Excel app
that nobody knows is running
uh maybe the Excel app everybody does
know is running you're breaking it on
purpose that's okay
um
and but the thing is just like with the
column it's going to change it's going
to break things into internally to the
database as well
right if you have a stored procedure who
actually likes writing stored procedures
yeah okay
that that's expected
who has to write stored procedures
because their DBA told team told them
they had to
we're getting places in the world
um
yeah it doesn't have to be all stored
products anyway
right but if you change the name of the
table you're going to break something
and unlike with the column where like
the engine might tell you
if there's a stored product that uses
the table that you just renamed it's not
going to tell you until you execute it
and it goes
it's a version of the this talk where I
had uh the Tony Stark with the explosion
in the background
but I thought it was a little too much
right so
we can either engage in some scream Ops
in this case
um
we can
use our observability tools right
which is a different form of screen Ops
as all of the monitors turn red
or you can whoops
you can define a view
right
so just like our computed column the
view is just going to say hey give me
all the columns out of my rename table
and I'm creating it with the name of my
old table
and then we can we can kind of
give ourselves some backwards
compatibility and some some Grace as we
move backwards in time
um
because otherwise we will inevitably
break something for somebody
okay but really kind of my point here is
we need to protect against broken
business logic
um
now there are a lot of different ways to
do this on on the code side of things
um I've seen good ones uh I've seen bad
ones
um
I've seen ones that work but you know
you kind of go like well that's a 40
minute build time with all those tests
is that really worth it
um
right on the code side we can we can
protect ourselves against it with with a
combination of unit and integration
testing whatever that looks like in your
environment
but on the database side right
how do we do that we don't we don't
really think about testing on the
database side
um who has business logic in their
database
does anybody have a foreign key in their
you have business logic
you might not think about it as such but
it is business logic
right
yeah so
and I should have put this slide up
before I asked for the hand so I could
actually see you guys
um
yeah unit testing is your friend right
unit testing is your friend on the
application side right
we we've all we've all known that for
like 15 years now right how long ago was
it that the art of unit testing came out
that Manning book with the samurai on
the front
like it's been a while right this is
part of our development process it's
ingrained to us now
um but we also should be thinking about
applying that to business logic in the
database
now
again
how many of you have a have a have a
unit test Suite that does a variant of
testing the framework
yeah come on
everybody knows that developer that's
like oh I'm going to get 100 unit test
coverage and like they're writing unit
tests on properties
come on no no
right
so when we think about unit testing our
database of business engineer database
like do we need a unit test foreign keys
probably not
like
if our database provider messed up the
implementation of a foreign key
we should be shopping for a new database
provider not like testing that it works
but like if we have a stored procedure
or a function or you know maybe some
sort of like
weird weirdly complicated view like
those things are candidates to be tested
right and they probably should be
um now there are a couple of ways that
you can
you can test in the database
you can write your own harness which is
what a lot of people do because this is
a kind of awkward thing to do in the SQL
Server World you've got T SQL t
and then there are a bunch of others in
in other parts of the world and
apparently my slide with them all has
gone missing because it should have been
next
um
but essentially like
the example here is so I've got a stored
procedure here on the left
um
and this is the
in the pretend world of running against
the stack Overflow database so
we've got uh
does this work it does
so we're just incrementing someone's
reputation right let's let's say they've
either gotten an upvote or gotten a down
vote
um and we have some decision points in
here right so like you know if the user
didn't get passed in we want to throw an
error if the reputation adjustment
amount didn't get passed in we want to
throw an error
um you know if we gave an invalid user
ID right so this is some sort of basic
sanity checking logic
um
we should be testing this right
um because not only are we testing that
our logic works but also regarding
against changes
so all of a sudden
if our users tables name change gets
changed
our unit test Suite will tell us because
it'll fail
right so we want to we want to do
something like that and in the t-sql T
World which is is what I've
come to prefer although it's not what we
use why work
um
it's really easy to write these sort of
uh
write these sort of unit tests
um
because it's just like hey
it looks looks really similar to what
you would write in C sharp like I'm
expecting this exception with this
message and this error number
and then I run the stored proc
and this can be integrated into your CI
CD pipeline as well
time check
now
when we think about deployments of our
application code
um
most of the time we're doing something
where it's
either a blue-green deployment
or
we have a previous version of the code
that we can roll back to
um
this is this is not so easy in database
world right so
in the database world
we should always be trying to roll
forward
um
and uh there's a there's a reason for
that so before I get there
um
right so when we talk about managing
managing database
source code right and that's what I mean
by that is the data definition language
so what are what our tables look like
our views our stored procedures those
types of things
um there are two versions state-based
tools which represents a bunch of SQL
files that represent this is what the
database should look like when I deploy
it
generates a script that you know looks
at whatever is there in the database
whatever is in the model generates a
script to fix the differences
um
two most notable examples SQL Server
database tools and Redgate SQL Source
control
um
and then the other side there are
migration based tools who here uses
Entity Framework
with code first yeah
oh God I love that love seeing that too
but yeah code first is is a version of
migration based Source migration based
Source console for your data model right
so you manage the
creation of migration skip scripts that
move the database from one version to
the next
and sometimes you can roll back as well
depends on the tool
and usually you maintain a baseline
version
so for example I mentioned earlier that
we wrote Our Own migration based
tool
and the reason we did that is because
nothing existed when it was written that
did what we needed it to do
which is essentially
allow us to deploy database changes
in any order so that we weren't tied to
a specific order of
pull requests being deployed
we deploy between six and eight times a
day so having that sort of flexibility
is really important
um
some other some commercial versions
Flyway liquibase Ruby on Rails
migrations probably the
the most famous and well-known one other
orm migration tools right Entity
framework code first that type of thing
right so this is how you're going to
store your database shape
now you'll notice something about
the state-based tools is that they
always generate a script to do the
change
and the migration based tool
you're always
changing
moving the database from one version to
the next
um
although if you pay Redgate for Flyway
Enterprise you can actually roll back
I've had talks with some people from
redgrate and they say yeah you really
shouldn't do that
we support it but don't do it
right but so why are we always rolling
forward
um and really the answer becomes if we
always are making changes based on
what's there and not trying to go
backwards
um the state of our database and
ensuring that state becomes much easier
right there's not a like have we
deployed this change or not situation
um
the other thing that we'll avoid is
if you are making a change that's
destructive to data and you have to roll
it back
so say you've or
take a different example say you've
you've changed the column width like so
I had a
had an email column that was a hundred
characters
that's just clearly wrong so we're going
to increase it to to 253.
well so I can go forwards with that
going backwards
that most database engines aren't going
to aren't going to let you do that
right
but if you roll forward then you can
write the code in such a way that like
okay well we need to undo this so I can
write a state change that undoes it
um unfortunately this isn't a Magic
Bullet
um
you might have to do a restore sometime
right the the goal of rolling forward is
to avoid having to do a database restore
um our main database is seven terabytes
now thanks to the magic of Google and
the cloud that restores in like
10 minutes
but that's still 10 minutes that our
application's offline
um
yeah
but the other piece is with rolling
forward is we want to make sure that our
changes are backwards compatible
um this is something that
that we do fairly easily with API design
right like versioning apis and making
sure that we're not going to break
something but we want to do it with our
database changes as well
now
I get to look at our Cloud Bill Storage
is not cheap
storage is not cheap uh
but it's cheaper than having the than
having the uh software be offline
so
and this of course
brings up a different issue
so
this is particularly important when
we're thinking about state-based changes
but it's good to keep in mind for
migration as well
um item potency is really important
right
so we want to be able to run the same
operation multiple times and not get
into an error state
so that means when you're doing database
deployments you check to see if the
change has already been made before you
actually executing the change I have
some examples of of that
and yes it gets complicated
but
this is why we get paid well
who wants to see some demos
yeah
all right
so
is that big enough
maybe one more all right
so
as I mentioned I chose a couple of
off-the-shelf one migration based one
state based and we'll take a look at the
state-based one first because it's um
maybe more interesting so
SQL Server data tools is was for a long
time Microsoft's like this is how you
should do database Source control
um and nobody used it
for various reasons
but essentially what we have is and I've
organized this by schema so I've got my
dbo tables I've got my data load which
is stored procedures and I use a defined
type
it's a fun story for another time about
why that came came into being
um and this is as as you might maybe
guess a database to store data on Lego
so rebreakable produces a data set with
all of the Lego sets Parts Minifigures
Etc from the last
however long it's been around
right and so
these SQL files and we can take a look
at one
describe the shape of the database
it's really really straightforward right
it's just to create table statement
um
I've got my primary key there a
clustered index I've had other indexes I
could put it in here I could put them in
different files
and when this thing gets compiled
together it creates uh what's
what Microsoft refers to as a DAC pack
dacpac
um
that then it's just a bunch of XML
because it's an Enterprise problem so
let's solve it with XML
um and then that thing can be deployed
against wherever you generally configure
a Target
in my case the targets uh
SQL Server
and uh
it's got what should look fairly
familiar to anybody who's done a lot of
c-sharp except instead of a CS project
it's a sequel prize
um
and uh unfortunately
I can't demo this work building locally
because haha the SQL Server data tools
don't work on a Mac
they don't work on an arm-based
processor either so I can't even boot up
parallels so
hopefully they'll fix that at some point
and then
essentially you can just build them
build this by
doing something like this
and it's just a visual studio build
um
and you this works in whatever build
system you use I'm using Azure devops
here you could use team City you could
use uh Jenkins you could use whatever
GitHub actions I think
although
note for SQL Server data tools because
it only runs on Windows you're going to
be paying for Windows agents in GitHub
so yeah
that's that's an additional bill
right
and uh yeah so let's
let's add a table right and I've done
some some demo already some demo scripts
already so I don't have to do a bunch of
typing here but we're just going to add
a parts ssdt demo table to this database
I guess I should prove that this doesn't
already exist there
and maybe wake my database up
right so got my continuous database to
play
server here and it did go to sleep
SQL Azure the serverless SQL Azure is
great for saving money but just be
careful how you can figure it's going to
sleep
so yeah you can see like my table list
here I don't have that table yet so
let's get it there
oh and there's there is data in this
database as well
just to prove those data in this
database
Maybe
there we go
yeah there's data in the database
right so about no uh no ignoring the man
behind the curtain here
so uh let's let's add this table and so
to do this in in the state base way
um literally all I have to do is I'm
going to drag it in here
yep I do want to move you thank you
um now we want to fill it with data as
well the way you do that in the
state-based world and in SQL Server data
tools is through what are called pre and
post deployment Scripts
um
so those uh post deployment scripts in
this case we're gonna
and this is uh this is what I'm talking
about about item potency right
so in this case if this table is here
fill it with data from the parts table
um and it's a small enough table that
it's not going to take forever when we
run it
so we'll come in here
set this guy to run
and the last thing I have to do is make
sure that
that table gets included in the build
we'll go ahead and get
push that up
the internet's cooperating all right we
can come over here
come back out to our Pipelines
go ahead and run this
and what this will do is it will
go ahead and
pull our changes
build that DAC pack as I was mentioning
uh failed to communicate with the agent
cloud
demo is a four-letter word
no So eventually we'll get an agent
otherwise this will be okay there we go
otherwise this would be real unfortunate
so
it's going to pull our changes it's
going to build that DAC pack and then in
our case
I've chosen to just go ahead and deploy
that DAC pack straight to the server
now note this is a demo you probably
don't want to do that
um
like you probably want to have a
separate deploy step uh particularly
with something like this
I also note that I'm running no tests of
any sort
um because again it's a demo
what you can see is we're actually we're
building and you get some similar output
to what you get from
normal C sharp
writes the model
you'll notice it's XML
because of course it is
this is also not incredibly fast
uh
when I ran it earlier it was not this
slow
I wonder if I'm
wonder if I'm running into uh
I guess the working days started in the
U.S I wonder if I'm still work running
on U.S agents there we go right so build
finished and then we'll deploy
and uh
you can't see my password so that's good
um
not that you can access this database
anyway because firewalls are good
you see it says okay here's the dacpac
file
and
do some initializing of deployments
so by running these things automated is
good because then you don't have to like
you know you can get up go up and get a
coffee and come back and you get the
answer
I I want to win something too
I never win anything at conferences
like never right okay so now we're
updating the database it says we're
creating the table says we're creating
the foreign key and it finished so fast
that it flipped away before I could talk
about it
um
yeah and so that's it right so
that this says it ran successfully Let's
uh let's go prove it
so we'll refresh the table list hey
there it is
Parts Associated underscore demo okay
now let's proved that the data ended up
in there
Azure data Studio has it in for me today
I also did not choose a very powerful
database okay yeah so you can see the
parts all in there right great
um what if we wanted to do the same
thing with a migration based tool
um
plot twist it's going to be much easier
so let's take a look at Flyway
so
flyways convention and many other
migration-based conventions is you have
a version identifier in my case I'm just
going
one two three four five
and then you name that version whatever
you want it to and it processes them in
order
um
and literally all it does is process
them in order
we can take a look at the con
configuration file you can see
um
yep
configuration file is pretty useless
because it's just for local
but if we want to
do a parts Flyway demo right so now this
is the same thing I just did in the
state base but with migrations and this
looks a lot simpler doesn't it
this is a lot nicer looking
at least from a developer standpoint
like I had to do a lot of stuff in the
other one
all I have to do on this one is
well let's move it
[Music]
push it up
it's up there
and they're having a lot of fun down
there
I wouldn't blame you guys if you left
um and so we'll take a look at this
pipeline because this is this is a lot
simpler
um there are a lot of different ways to
run Flyway I'm just installing the tools
on the build machine
and running a migration
but essentially all this does is run
Flyway migrate with a bunch of
parameters including the uh user the
name jdbc URL
um
and that's it that's that's pretty much
what it does so we'll take a look at
this
you'll notice this is also a lot faster
even with having to install the tools on
the build machine
fail to communicate with the agent Cloud
again my lucky day
yeah okay so
check out normal
they use flyways I'm just going to
install that particular version which is
quite nice
I have uh on occasion updated
my local Flyway and broken everything
which is why I do this in the cloud now
right so we run the migration
and you'll be able to see the
yes
yes so
it says fly away right
gives me my database
successfully validated 14 migrations my
schema was on 13 right that table wasn't
there the migration hadn't been
performed
it says okay migrate it applied one
migration so we're now at version 14.
and uh that was quick right so let's go
prove it
close this guy
hey our Flyway demo table is there now
too
and I bet it has data in it
note to self next time just have these
queries ready to go
yeah
so we got data right and it happens to
be the same data which is fine
okay
but like I said in the in in the slides
adding things is really easy
let's go rename things
and we'll start with renaming
in
ssdt
right so
now for this all I have to do
in our state based
do you guys still hear me even though
over the stuff there yeah okay good then
I'm just gonna keep talking
so in my state base right because State
the state-based database project says
this is how my database should look
so all I have to do is swap my ssdt demo
with underscores with the one that
doesn't have underscores right because
we all use underscores and SQL Server
it's weird
so I'll move that in there
move this back out there
okay
swap around what we're actually uh
including in the build
and
we'll have two
deployment scripts why do we need two
that's weird we're just renaming the
table
well
let's take a look at what we're doing in
those
so
because we can't be sure
how this changed the state change is
going to be executed right now logically
it says if I execute a rename in SQL
Server I'm just going to use rename
right or if I'm in postgres alter table
rename right
but we can't guarantee that's how our
our state-based tool is going to
actually do it so
right we're going to need to preserve
that data somehow because what if it
issues drop table create table
anybody played around with uh
with Atlantis for terraform management
yeah if you change if you change the
name of something it drops it and
recreates it
nah not what you want necessarily right
so
if we have our old table name
we're going to create a temp table and
copy our data into it
on the front side
so that then
you know
we don't have to deal with it
and then on the back side
sorry this one
right insert into the newly renamed
table
and drop the temp table
this is kind of a pain but
this is what we're working with we're
working with state right
we have to think about how we're moving
the database from one state to the other
so we'll go ahead save these things
and
as a as an aside
we're going to get some much more
interesting output
when we go run the build
when you finish you finished
run a pipeline
right and
and three for three
when I do the migration based demo of
this we'll see if I get four from four
um
right and so
the reason that nobody has really used
ssdt or not no one but the reason the
the adoption level is fairly low is
because that sort of like
let me awkwardly work around how state
is managed is really can be really prone
to error
um and if you don't know what's
happening
um
now there are some some guard rails like
if I had just run that with the data in
the table it would have said
I can't make this change because there's
data in the table and the the change
might be destructive which is nice but
it's also not what you want in your
continuous process
um
building the database building a
database
come on and get to the interesting part
all right
there we go
as an aside uh if you uh if you've
enjoyed NDC Oslo
um definitely think about coming down to
Copenhagen for the Copenhagen developer
Festival
um
it's held in a really interesting part
of the city
there's a really awesome uh barbecue and
beer place nearby
um
and it should be a really good time
I've apparently used up all of my Azure
devops Karma
for today
well while we're waiting for this I'll
go ahead and come back over here and and
make the make the change for the
migration one
um
and so
that's all I have to do for the
migration one
none of that like let's swap some tables
around and let's run a couple of files
it's just
let's rename the table
and uh so
go ahead and push this in here
we'll go ahead and
ah
third time's the charm oh hey uh
why are you stuck
all right
well
it was worth a try have you tried
turning it off and back on again
am I still on over here
yep I'm still on over here maybe
hmm
did we
well
you would have seen a really cool
looking demo
uh but
ah here we go
I have confidence in you
wow okay
sometimes you win the build agent
Lottery and sometimes you don't uh
so we'll just puts what we'll call that
one
um
yeah okay cool now we're publishing
um and what you'll see is we'll start
the deployment
and it will run
our pre-deployment
yeah all right well
I give up
but it's before four o'clock
yeah
so it it's funny because okay there we
go it's it's funny you say that it's a
gentleman says it's Friday I just never
deployed a database on Friday
um
it's uh it's interesting because as I
mentioned we deploy six to eight times a
day and that does include Friday
um
and uh
yeah we shouldn't be afraid of deploying
on Friday
um but if we are we should look at why
that is so anyway that's a side note
right so uh
you see we did some stuff
and if we come back over here we will
now see
that it has been renamed
but our old table has not been dropped
which is interesting
so something went wrong
which I will have to look at at a
different time
in any case we're nearly at time for
this talk uh I have time for a couple of
questions
yep
yeah so the question was can the
migration tool be run on a remote
location like say on a customer location
or does it need to be run locally or on
the build machine and the answer at
least for Flyway is um
you can run it wherever you want it's a
command line tool you can install it you
can run it in a Docker container
it has no no Reliance on running on a
build machine so that can be a very
useful thing and particularly if you
have
remote databases that you need to update
anybody else
[Music]
do Flyway or other tools check for
manual changes so
um
you might have noticed that my my state
base deploy did not destroy my Flyway
tables and the reason for that is
because I set it not to
Flyway doesn't Flyway only executes
Flyway and other migration based tools
generally only execute
um
your your what you've written as scripts
and it ignores any other changes that
have been made in the database and if
there's a conflict then the script just
fails
right
state-based tools generally
say this is the state I expect in the
database
this is the state you've given me so I'm
going to wipe away everything that I
don't know about
now as you can see you can set it to
ignore other changes but then it ignores
all the other changes
um so that there's a there's a trade-off
there
I mentioned we were on our own
migration-based tool one of the reasons
we did it was so that we could get
um a bit of State
checking as part of our deployment
all right
it is four o'clock so
thank you guys all for coming I
appreciate it I hope you had a great
conference
um and enjoy the the ending Keynote